someone who obviously knows how I
operate send me a tweet last night and
said can this please not be what you
talk about tomorrow and he's referring
to of course fart date the fart heard
around the world the fart that changed
the course of history that is
representative Eric's well well farting
on live TV last night this person who
sent me this obviously knows me well but
at the same time knows me not at all
because there is no way that I could
open the show
the day after such an event talking
about anything but this story we could
literally have landed on Mars in the
meantime and discovered a sentient race
of unicorns who possess the cure to
diabetes and herpes and I still would be
talking about this first why well
because it's clearly the most important
political story of our time I dare you
to come up with a more important story
can you but it's a story like any
political story that is not without
controversy so first let's uh let's go
right to the tape you've already seen
the footage but we're gonna go and we're
gonna look at it again we're gonna use
our eyes and our ears and or even even
our noses and we're going to try to take
a closer look here is Chris or Eric's
well well with Chris Matthews talking
about well I don't know what he was
talking about it doesn't matter it's not
the conjectures of his mouth we are
concerned with right now but take a
listen the evidence is uncontradicted
that the president used taxpayer dollars
to ask the Ukrainians to help him cheat
an election and the complaint that I've
heard from now sois well according to a
BuzzFeed report has denied that he was
the source of the rectal emission he
seems to want to blame somebody
off-camera he's scrambling now okay this
is a man who was panicked this is like a
man who you know lets out a fart in the
office break room because he's alone
only to have somebody walk into the room
three seconds later and now it's only
him and
the person and the putrid stench and
they both know what happened so what's
he gonna do
is he gonna face up to it or is he going
to come up with a wild story swell well
of course lacks the honour to own his
deeds and the deeds of his lower
intestines and there are fart truthers
out there right now who want to insert
kind of assist him in this cover-up
coming up with elaborate conspiracy
theories some people are even blaming
Chris Matthews okay Chris Matthews the
elderly man engaging in stereotypes and
say well he's the older guy of course
he's the one who farted accusing
Matthews of framing sois well which if
that were true would would be completely
awesome it would actually make Chris
Matthews maybe one of the great American
heroes in our country's history but
that's not true okay the wisdom of the
third-grader as always holds here he who
denies it indeed supplies it and Eric's
whoa well last night had an abundance of
supply he had a veritable surplus but I
don't want you to take my word for it I
want you to let's well wails flatulence
speak for itself let's go back to the
tape I want you to watch it again and
this time pay close attention to swells
body language and his speech patterns so
watch one more time the evidence is
uncontradicted that the president used
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help him cheat an election and the
complaint that I've heard from notice
how he pauses right at the crucial
moment and this this is key right here
this is what it all comes down to did he
pause a millisecond before ignition did
he if he did he's guilty notice - how
slightly elevates his body there's a
slice very subtle but there's a slight
turn of the body and what he's doing is
he's trying to clear passageway for a
silent emission that's what he thinks
it's gonna happen there's a drama
unfolding in his mind and in his bowels
he knows something is coming okay he you
can tell it in his face his facial
expression he is pregnant with with with
dread and anticipation and the
chimichanga that he had for dinner so I
want you to look look at this look at
the freeze-frame of his face three
seconds before liftoff this is what he
looked like now he knows a fart is
coming he knows what's coming but he
makes two crucial errors he pauses right
before the event and fatally his fart
deceived him now he's expecting a a
silent ejection but instead it bursts
forth
with vigor it came out announcing itself
loud and proud and opinionated and and
you could see in swallows face the
dejection the panic the despair that
feeling of betrayal and we've all been
betrayed in this way it's just that not
usually on live TV
Josh Jordan on Twitter has a slow motion
video that puts I think all doubt to
rest because here you're gonna see this
is what this is what's gonna settle it
you're going to see the pause right
before the fart lot to watch one more
time there it is pause the lift the fart
and if you needed any more corroboration
here's Eric's wawel 2013 this is his own
Twitter account speaking to a group of
Democrats on st. Patrick's Day his
message and this is real I promise this
was his message he says may the wind
always be at your back but let your
ideas move you forward the wind at your
back
Eric's whoa well new six years ago what
he was going to do
isn't about what he knew was gonna
happen three seconds before he's been
planning this for years everything has
been leading up to this moment this was
not just some errant gas passed by an
innocent man on a normal Monday this his
whole career has been leading to this he
had always planned to loll us into a
false sense of security so that he could
come along when we least expected when
we weren't paying attention we weren't
prepared when we were utterly
defenseless
and fart in our collective faces Eric's
whoa whoa
Eric fart well Eric fart smell Eric
don't smell well this man's a mad genius
and in the end he won this is a story
for the ages and this is a fart that
will live for all time and now a word
from brick house nutrition have you ever
wondered why so many Americans seem to
be sick unhealthy overweight between the
food supply the sedentary lifestyle
Americans are in the worst shape that
they've ever been and and that's why the
team of on staff physicians at
brickHouse nutrition created field of
greens field of greens is an easy way
for you to add fruits and vegetables to
your daily routine without spending
hours in the produce section without
hiring a home chef or taking cheap
supplements and I know I've discovered
this as a parent that just keeping a
supply of produce and fruits and stuff
in the house is very very difficult when
you've got a bunch of kids and produce
is also super expensive field of greens
oh that's where they come in they're
made with real USDA organic fruits and
vegetables it also helps to boost your
immunity using antioxidants and assist
digestive health with prebiotics
probiotics it's like having a doctor
nutritionist right in your kitchen one
scoop delivers a full serving of fruits
and vegetables he's dropping in a cup of
water stir drink it you're done it's
also great for smoothies very easy
nutritional it's got everything you want
bottom line this is real food not
extracts and you will look and feel
better go to brick house Walsh com get
15% off your first order just for trying
it out with promo code Walsh
that's brick house Walsh dot-com promo
code Walsh okay all this
of farting I think is it's a good segue
here into the fast-food chick-fil-a one
of the now and I'll admit although it is
fast-food it's one of the less gaseous
fast foods out there a to its credit but
also it had been one of the last
remaining large companies to stand in
defiance of PC police and the LGBTQ Rage
mob yet they have suddenly and
inexplicably caved as you may have heard
yesterday chick-fil-a president and
chief operating officer
Tim Casa polis Tessa Palace announced in
an interview that the company is no
longer gonna donate to certain Christian
charities that the affirmation rage mob
has deemed anti LGBT Tessa Paulo Louis
says that as the company goes into quote
new markets he wants to quote be clear
about who we are once we clear about who
we are and who they are appears to
confirm the old you know maximum about
you are what you eat well in this case I
guess they are what they serve the
website biz now has a little bit more
information says quote beginning next
year chick-fil-a will move away from its
current philanthropic structure busines
has learned after donating to more than
three hundred charitable organizations
through the year the Atlanta based
fast-food chain will instead focus on
three initiatives with one accompanying
charity each education homelessness and
hunger and which charities now are going
to lose out now that chick-fil-a has
shifted focus to education homelessness
and hunger well the company has
confirmed its breaking ties with
Salvation Army the Fellowship of
Christian Athletes and the poly Anderson
youth home in other words it will stop
donating to charities that help with
education homelessness and hunger in
order to focus on education homelessness
and hunger if that makes any sense which
it doesn't but of course we know the
real sin of these unfortunate
organizations is not that they fail to
help exactly the people that chick-fil-a
claims it wants to help but that they're
all Christian and as LGBT protesters
have been screaming ever since
chick-fil-a founder or CEO Dan Cathy
defended biblical marriage in that
interview but seven
years ago ever since then and they
haven't gotten over it in seven years
they couldn't get over it but ever since
then they've been saying that the fact
that chick-fil-a donates to Christian
charities makes them anti LGBT the very
fact that the charities are Christian
makes them anti LGBT and finally I guess
chick-fil-a agrees speaking of the
Salvation Army we talked about this last
week just last week the pop singer Ellie
Goulding threatened to pull out of her
halftime performance during the Dallas
Cowboys Thanksgiving game because of the
NFL's association with the Salvation
Army
of course Goulding did relent on that
threat and every football fan wishes
that she hadn't that's one thing we
really wish you wish she would have
stuck by her guns on that one because
none of us are interested in hearing a
halftime performance from Ellie Goulding
whoever that is but she pulls out or she
relents on that threat and then
chick-fil-a decides to jump on the dog
pile anyway a week later essentially
implicitly endorsing this idea that the
Salvation Army is quote anti LGBT now
this change of heart is confounding
because yes they've been boycotted on
and off for the past seven years yes
LGBT activists have been lashing out
against them yes they've been accused of
making hate chicken whatever that is and
if that if that was hate chicken then I
guess hate is very this is pretty tasty
it's a pretty tasty ingredient we
discovered over the last seven years I
don't know if that's something they mix
into the breading or say you know I mean
I've made fried chicken sandwiches I
can't make them as good as chick-fil-a
maybe it's because I'm not putting
enough hate into it but anyway yes they
they've been accused of that but none of
that has negatively affected the bottom
line in fact the opposite was the case
the initial boycott in 2012 gave rise to
chick-fil-a Appreciation Day which I
remember I went to chick-fil-a that day
and there were lines literally around
the block there were lines wrapping
around the store hundreds of people
waiting in line to show their support
for chick
play by eating purchasing and eating the
tasty chicken sandwich
and the enthusiasm never really died
down
chick-fil-a rose in popularity during
the intervening years tripling its sales
becoming one of the top three restaurant
chains in the country so this was a not
just an example of a company refusing to
relent - an outraged mob but this was a
company thriving in spite of it and I
think partially because of it
now most people who have been
chick-fil-a customers over the last
seven years myself included we weren't
going there just because of all this we
were going there because we like the
food but I think most of us and I know
I've done this before there have been
times when you're not really sure what
you're in the mood for and you need a
quick bite and you're going down a
stretch of road and there's 50 different
fast-food restaurants all around and
you're trying to decide who to go with
you decide chick-fil-a and what
chick-fil-a stands for and their courage
and standing up to the LGBT rage mob
does factor into that decision so it's
sort of like when there's a tie and
you're trying to decide between two
options for food that becomes a
tiebreaker or at least that's how it
works for me and I suspect for a lot of
other people
so this capitulation it's not like it's
going to stop the bleeding because there
was no bleeding now there might be so
this move is much more likely to
alienate chick-fil-a supporters than to
appease its critics this is prior to
this they had upset people who for the
most part weren't even chick-fil-a
customers to begin with and they were so
worried about upsetting their non
customers that now they're upsetting
their actual customers that is not a
smart business decision surrender
surrendering to political correctness
never pays off and chick-fil-a is not
going to be the exception to that rule
now personally let me just say I don't
care what charities chick-fil-a donates
to that's their decision
they're right there fair I don't care
and I'm not saying I'm gonna boycott
chick-fil-a now because I'm not their
chick their chicken sandwiches are still
delicious and if I'm in the mood for it
and they're in there's a chick-fil-a
there I'm gonna go there and when I'm in
the drive-through or during lunch my
primary concern is is the food good I'm
not thinking about the politics and
everything else but it is still
disappointing and it's it's really
somewhat bewildering to see them cave
like this their refusal until now was
important for reasons that have nothing
to do with gay marriage or homosexuality
it was just good to have at least one
major company with the stones to defy
the Rage mob and it was good to see this
example of them again doing that and
thriving because of it where you see
that you don't have to not only do you
not have to surrender to the rage mob
and not only will it not help you but it
may actually profit you if you don't so
regardless of the reason for their
defiance of the rage mob or the issue at
the center of the controversy regardless
of that just the defiance itself was the
point it's the principle of the thing
and their surrender on the other hand
has no point and this is what
chick-fil-a is is now gonna learn the
hard way as have so many before them
you cannot appease the mob it doesn't
matter if you give them what they want
it doesn't matter if you fall to your
feet confessing your sins begging
forgiveness all that your self
abdication will do is empower and
encourage your critics it's it's not
gonna get them to forgive you not that
chick-fil-a had anything to be forgiven
for in the first place but this is not
we don't live in a culture of
forgiveness this is a culture of scalp
claiming this is you take the scalp if
somebody falls to your feet asking for
get forgiveness you scalp them that's
that's what we do now in this culture
and so now for chick-fil-a yeah they're
gonna happily take
scalp they're gonna celebrate the
victory and they're gonna move on to
their next target
you aren't their friend now you aren't
their ally you're just a trophy on the
shelf so congratulations for that
in fact glad the the gay organization
Gay and Lesbian Alliance whatever it's
called they released a statement
yesterday and I don't have a statement
in front of me but it's it's it's
exactly this they didn't read they
didn't release a statement saying oh we
forgive you chick-fil-a for your
horrible hate chicken and we're so happy
that we welcomed you with open arms and
we're gonna now we're all gonna show up
the chick-fil-a and buy chicken they
didn't say that what they basically said
was okay good for you but you're still
bigots you're you're still
discriminatory you still need to do ABC
XYZ one through three here here are
steps we still need you to follow
they're not satisfied they're never
going to be I've mentioned before that
the children's book if you give a mouse
a cookie is I think one of the most
prophetic books of our time and in that
book that books all about if I remember
it's it's been a while since I've read
it but in that book you've got a greedy
gluttonous psychotic Mouse who demands a
cookie from this kid and the kid gives
the cookie and thinks that okay the
mouse is me happy now cuz he got his
cookie but then oh he wants a glass of
milk and then know he wants a napkin and
no and actually wants uh you know he
wants a sandwich to he's still hungry
and now he wants a glass of water and
and before long it's that this kid is
destitute living on the street homeless
and starving that's how the book ends
it's pretty dark at least as I recall
but the point is you you give them one
thing and they want another and another
and another and and they're just they're
never ever satisfied ever and that's
what I'm check filet all they had to do
was look at examples around them okay
Dick's Sporting Goods decides to start
destroying their own guns to try to make
friends with the left the left still
isn't impressed and besides these people
aren't really customers of Dick's
Sporting Goods in the first place
these aren't sporty people these aren't
outdoorsy people who are going and
buying fishing tackle or anything like
that
not they're not going there and buying a
you know baseball or a football helmets
or whatever baseball gloves it they're
not doing that so you've you've tried to
appease them they're not impressed
they're not even customers of yours to
begin with and they're not going to be
now and Dick's Sporting Goods lost
millions of dollars in the meantime boy
the Boy Scouts the Boy Scouts basically
self-immolated they just set their whole
organization on fire to please the left
said that okay we're not Boy Scouts
anymore you don't even have to be a boy
you'll be a girl you know transgender
gay everything we're all we're bringing
it all in the left still doesn't care
they're not impressed
now the Boy Scouts are basically
bankrupt they think of many examples of
this kind of thing the NFL appeasing the
left on the anthem thing yet again
didn't pay off chick-fil-a looks at all
these examples Gillette ok Gillette
comes out with a with a with an ad
insulting their own customers
denigrating masculinity and they they
have this ad they offer it up on the
altar as a sacrifice to the left
saying please masters look what we have
presented we've we have we've we've we
have burned our own customers of the
stake as a burnt offering to you do you
accept our sacrifice and the left says
snap get out of here you still suck
Gillette loses millions of dollars
chick-fil-a sees all of these examples
and they say yeah let me give that a
shot absolutely crazy but
you know what Popeyes is better anyway
so here's and now a word from policy
genius tis the season to elect benefits
through your workplace most people know
that open enrollment is decision time
for health care coverage but it's it's
also the perfect moment to reassess your
life insurance needs and think about
what you actually need what your family
needs to properly provide for their
families most people need 10 times life
insurance coverage that they currently
get through their jobs so most people if
you're like most people on average
you're getting a tenth of what you need
your family is getting a tenth of what
they're going to need which means that
your employer life insurance is leaving
you underinsured
that is where policy genius can help
policy genius is the easy way to shop
for a life insurance plan that's not
tied to your job in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price and once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork all the red tape they're gonna
take care of all that you don't have to
worry about it
so it's makes it very easy on you the
life insurance you buy through policy
genus stays with you even if you leave
your job so when you're looking at your
workplace benefits this month make sure
to double check your life insurance
options then go to policy genius.com to
get quotes and apply in minutes policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance okay
okay somebody emailed this to me and I
want to go over it with you because I
think it's a really perfect example of
how the left tends to operate mainly by
tossing labels around with no regard for
the actual reality with no attempt to be
coherence in the placement of the labels
that they're tossing around so the
website pink news has a big headline
headline is right-wing religious bigot
right wing right wing religious bigot
for been Shapiro's daily wire manages to
be transphobic and racist in just 27
seconds and this of course is about
yours truly and that is pretty efficient
on me you have to admit transphobic and
racist in 27 seconds it's got to be a
Guinness Book you know record right
there but let's let's take a look at the
article and see how they because they've
made two accusations here in the
headline transphobic racist
let's see how they present the evidence
that I am those things it says Matt
Walsh a frequent writer for the
religious right I'm a frequent writer
for the religious right they say I'm not
a writer for the daily wire I'm a writer
for the religious right as an
organization the religious right
organization has hired me as a writer
they sent me in assignments via email
their email address religious right at
gmail.com and they tell me what to write
about and so I write about whatever they
say
so says Matt Walsh a frequent writer for
the Religious Right spoke earlier this
week at the California State University
Los Angeles the event was hosted by the
young Americans for freedom a
conservative youth group The Daily wires
founder ben shapiro is a vocal
right-wing campaigner who has
consistently hit out against the trans
and non-binary communities while
speaking in front of a packed room walsh
said that trans people cheapen womanhood
and compared their existence to a
costume that a man can wear that's true
I did say both those things he added if
it's cultural appropriation for a white
man to dress like a black man isn't it
all the more appropriation for a man to
dress like a woman he went further to
claim that trans people's very existence
ferments confusion in the minds of
children I said foments but really
ferments works too I suppose
and and that trans people reduced gender
to an abstract concept that we theorize
about walleston alleged Walsh then said
this is especially ironic considering
the concern for cultural appropriation
Walsh then alleged that some parents
first realized that their boy is a girl
because he played with dolls a boy with
dolls used to be girly now used now
you're saying he's literally a girl if a
boy who exhibits womanly characteristics
is therefore a girl than those gender
constructs far from being torn down are
far more potent and powerful than any
conservative ever made them out to be
that was meat they were quoting me there
a number of Twitter users lit into
Walsh's transphobic and racist words and
then they quote a bunch of random
Twitter people complaining about me
and that's it okay that's it that's the
article do you notice something here
maybe you noticed it
because they they came in hot with the
headline and in they're making big
claims transphobic and racist in 27
seconds there is no attempt made none at
all to actually explain how what I said
qualifies this transphobic or even what
transphobic actually means because I got
to be honest with you I don't even know
what that means
I am familiar with the term I hear it a
lot I don't know what you mean by that
but you could explain it no attempt made
his days didn't even didn't even try and
there's also no Ted may attack to
explain why I'm wrong so they quote me
he's saying a bunch of stuff and they
did quote me accurately except for the
one word they got wrong but that's fine
and I'm and I'm glad they quoted that
because I'm you know I'm reading back
the article just now and I'm thinking
wow I made some great points those are
actually really good points I got to
give that speech again so to me I read
that now I'm biased of course because
I'm the one who said it but but to me I
read that and I think well those are
legitimate points I don't know what the
problem is here if there's a problem you
could try to explain what the issue is
but again they don't even try I'm
alleging that men who dressed like women
are appropriating womanhood yes that is
my allegation I i yes that is exactly
what I'm saying how is that bigoted
explain to me how it's bigoted please
explain it and and forget about bigoted
just explain why it's wrong you don't
even have to I'll let you go with a
bigoted thing I don't even care just
explain how I'm wrong where do I go
wrong where is the error see I run into
this all the time when I talk about this
issue and I and I make points like this
especially with things like you know
it's an appropriation of womanhood in
that same
I say that men dressing and drag is like
a female blackface degrading offensive a
caricature a mockery and that's another
one where I think actually the media
matters they a few days ago they they
got me on the on the female blackface
thing they they posted a thing on their
Twitter saying that I'm a bigot for that
again not explaining why is that bigoted
also why is it wrong and I'm and I'm not
exaggerating or this is I seriously I
have yet to hear from one single leftist
LGBT you know activist any any of these
people I've heard for many of them
screaming at me calling me a bigot
saying how dare you saying I've heard
I've heard from them not a single one of
them has even tried to actually engage
with the point that I'm making and
demonstrate why it's wrong not a single
one so I open the invitation again so
anyone who happens to be watching this
and I know Media Matters is watching
this and so media matters maybe if you
want to do me a favor and you're always
clipping my show and I appreciate all
the promo the promotion you do for the
show and it's really been it has been
indispensable I'm serious and I do thank
you for that if you maybe want to clip
what I'm saying right now put it on your
Twitter I mean this is a challenge I'm
opening to any liberal leftist LGBT
whatever anyone who disagrees with me
the points that I just read from that
pink news article explain why I'm wrong
try I dare you to try because I don't
think you can it's just like the
challenge I have put forth a million
times about define what the word woman
what is a woman no one's done it yet so
I once again I throw it out there please
just give it a shot yes I say that a man
dressing up like a woman is an
appropriation of womanhood
it is the very
definition of appropriation tell me why
I'm wrong and then hilariously they
throw in the charge of racism completely
at random
the writer doesn't even get into the
ballpark of explaining why I'm racist
they this racist this is me where are
you getting that from
I think at this point it's it's an
instinct for these people they just they
they can't help it on the Left they they
it's it's it's like it's Tourette's
syndrome at this point they hear a point
they don't like and it's just racist
transphobic homophobic it doesn't even
matter what was said racist okay you've
got a lot of work to do in explaining
why I'm transphobic whatever that means
work that again begins with explaining
what the word even means you got a lot
of work to do there but to explain why
that is racist go ahead again III
welcome encourage ask for I plead for
someone to try to engage with these
points tell me how it's racist
this is why you know labels we're at a
point now where these labels just don't
really mean anything anymore because you
you've used you use them all the time
and and they have become synonymous with
I don't agree with you so when you call
what the person who wrote that headline
calling me racist obviously there's
nothing a racist in there what they mean
is I don't like this guy he makes me
upset he makes my tummy hurt and and and
so this is what I'm calling that's what
they mean when they say and that really
is a problem because you know even
though I'm not sure what transphobic
means I do know what racist means racism
is a real thing that exists in the world
not just in America not just in white
countries exist across the world it's
existed throughout history it's a bad
thing it has been the starting point for
many atrocities and human rights
violations and and and all kinds of
terrible awful bloody oppressive things
throughout history so racism is a real
thing and that's what makes it all the
worse that you on the Left have removed
all meaning from this word and talk
about cheapening and degrading things
you have cheapened the the word racism
so that now when you say that the word
and you call someone racist it could be
that the person you're calling racist
actually is racist because there are
racist people out there so it's possible
that you could mean that but you could
also just it could also just be a temper
tantrum it could also just be verbal
diarrhea it could just be the leftist
version of Tourette's syndrome and I
don't know because of how you have
hollowed out this term from your
consistent relentless abuse of it
before he gets emails in honor of the
hilarious self owned by Liz Warren
tweeting that she's selling billionaire
tears mugs on Shopify that actually are
gonna enrich its billionaire founder we
here at the Daily wire are offering 20%
off all off all access and Insider Plus
subscriptions when you use the promo
code warren tears and with the insider
plus and all access you get the
incredible leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler today is the last day to join so
again that's promo code warring tears
for 20% off on your subscription come
join the fun ok let's go to emails this
is from Curtis says I've got another
food to be outlawed in your benevolent
dictatorship chilli and cinnamon rolls
have have chili and similar similar
roles have nothing on this one
my wife enjoys pizza dipped in apple
sauce pizza dipped in apple sauce she's
trying to indoctrinate our children on
this one what are your thoughts Curtis
listen man I'm not telling you
to get a divorce I'm not saying that's
for you to decide but you need to get
your children out of that house get them
out they cannot be exposed to this
trauma and it is your duty to protect
them from it this is from David thanks
for the work you do I'm a big fan of the
show apart from the potpourri currently
living in Oxford England I always enjoy
listening to the show as I cycle to and
from work I'm just gonna move past that
David I'll let that slide
I'll let it slide that's this time
although I live in the in the UK
I am half American a US citizen and
married to a proud Oklahoman so I like
to think that I can approach this topic
from a somewhat neutral position the
monarchy and Britain far from being a
drain on the taxpayer is a massive net
contributor to the British County
economy they live off 15% of the profits
from their estates pay tax most
importantly they draw millions of people
from all around the world and especially
the u.s. to visit the UK the queen who
is almost universally respected as a
unifying figure because she provides a
non-political head of state who is liked
by most people to represent the country
contrasting with the u.s. system where
50% of the people hate the president at
any given time
lastly the monarchy serves as a reminder
of the history of the country it's
Christian roots and the long process by
which representatives democracy came to
exist alongside a constitutional
monarchy
not to mention this struggle against
Romish tyranny and treachery you're I
mean you're you're really trying to
incite me right now I'm trying to stay
focused on the monarchy topic here
though it is it is interesting to me
that you are defending the monarchy
based on things like tradition
preserving tradition and then but then
you're thrown in is anti-catholic anti
Pope things I actually see a conflict
there but anyway well I am NOT saying by
any means that the UK system is perfect
or better than the American one but I
thought I would let you know some
positive reasons to keep hold of this
tradition I hope I will see you at a UK
tour sometime in the future yeah
I understand the arguments on the
monarchy not the anti-catholic stuff I
understand what you're saying and I as I
said yesterday I think preserving
tradition is a wonderful thing and I
think we should do it
and I think knowing your history is a
wonderful thing but that's also where
things like museums come into play so
you could have a museum where people go
and they learn their history and they
learn about their traditions that's all
great
my concern is in this stemmed as you
recall from talking about Prince Andrew
the playing the BBC interview he has
been accused credibly accused I would
say of raping a child he was a pal of
Jeffrey Epstein who was a well-known sex
trafficker and pedophile convicted at
the time when Prince Andrew was known to
have hung out with him and stayed at his
house
and he's basically impervious from maybe
not maybe he maybe not technically
legally but he's in effect impervious
and he can get up there and make these
offer these excuses that are really the
worst alibis
I've ever heard where he actually says
that he couldn't have been the one who
did it because he didn't sweat at the
time stuff like that so the way that
this figurehead faux royalty offers a
cover for criminals and alleged sex
predators that's me is a big problem and
I don't know if it makes it if the if
the tradition and the tourists I don't
know that really compensates for that
rather big legal and moral downside this
is from Joe says Joe here big fan of the
show since we're on the topic of Capra
dick in his recent antics I thought I'd
weigh in and run past you what I think
is really going on here the NFL settled
with cap 450 million dollars how many
employers do you know that are eager to
hire someone that just sued them every
owner in the league knows that if they
bring him on the consequences would far
outweigh any benefit they don't actually
want him kapppa
over 150 million dollars do you really
think he wants to be a backup QB in the
league he and Nike just want to control
the narrative he doesn't want to play he
doesn't want to debate he wants to play
SJW without any resistance at all
it's basically political posturing on
both sides cap needs to do something to
remain relevant he needs to earn his
Nike dollars
Nike wants him to do stuff like this
they signed him to a 100 million dollar
contract to be an sjw not a football
player he asked to perform somehow this
is the perfect opportunity for him to do
that the NFL is willing to take a stand
for anything that hurts their ratings
and is trying to play both sides of the
fence so they're obviously going to show
up and play along with cap and pretend
they're woek but at the same time
dedicated to vets flags flag and country
really they still just haven't figured
out a way to handle the situation and
have an ounce of integrity the NFL paid
cap 50 million for him to go away he's
not going away he's gonna keep putting
the pressure on them in the future and
they'll continue to cower and fumble
through awkward and neutral responses
towards him
meanwhile Kaepernick and I key win as
they keep their narrative alive and
kicking in the global spotlight stronger
than ever
all they needed is an occasional
appearance from their SJW icon I agree a
hundred percent with everything you said
and I would I would again emphasize that
we see an analogy here between the NFL
and their approach to this and the
anthem and Kaepernick with trying to
appease and how that has it worked out
for them and they've lost money in the
meantime and it has it hasn't it hasn't
satiated the critics at all so you see
an analogy between that and what
chick-fil-a has just done and I think
they're gonna suffer a very similar fate
finally this is from Carla hi Matt I
listened to your show every day as I
pick up around the house your sweat all
come in made me literally laugh out loud
which is a little odd when you're home
alone my question is how would you like
me to respond to my kids ages twenty six
and 20 when they make fun of me for
quoting you on a regular basis as soon
as I lead off with I heard of the Matt
Walsh show today the ridicule starts I
figured what better way to come back at
them than a specific quote from you you
want a quote for your traitorous
children okay I'll give you one
get out of my house and never come back
you have disgraced the family name
you are disowned get out that's that's
your quote and I want you to say it
exactly like that and then watch them
leave your life forever and I know
they're your children and I know that
you you you love them or at least you
did before this but we got to draw lines
and honestly if they're not so it's not
only that they that they don't listen to
my podcast but they make fun of you for
quoting it there you know we like to
talk about unconditional love but let's
be real there are conditions and this is
one of them but thanks for listening
anyway I appreciate it and thanks
everybody for watching I'll talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there